in this video we'll be testing
archicad's performance on the brand new
m1 ultra mac studio against a custom
built bim machine we're going to find
out if the 6 000 plus price tag is worth
it or if you can get away with spending
just half of that before we begin i want
to make it clear that archicad is still
running on rosetta 2 for the m1
architecture which means it's not native
to apple's m1 architecture just yet that
also means that these results will
improve by the end of 2022 so if you
want to see those results make sure you
smash that subscribe button down below
to see the latest video at the end of
this year today's testing will focus on
four main factors template load times
export times render times and general
archicad performance i'm going to be
testing all of these four categories
across two different sections a small
residential home and also a large
commercial project for me it's large for
others it might be considered medium so
hopefully this video will provide you
with enough value regardless of your
situation so first of all we're going to
be starting with a basic template load
time this is a personal template i'm
developing it is relatively bare bones
and basic on a high-end bim machine it
loaded in 25.7 seconds
whilst on an m1 ultra it loaded in only
10.75 seconds which means the m1 ultra
is 58.3
faster in low time for this specific
category if you have a much more
powerful template that's intended for
commercial use well then on the pc it
loaded in 47.2 seconds whilst on the
brand new mac studio it loaded in
20.31 seconds making it 57.1 percent
faster now you might be thinking this
video is going to continue that same
trend well i'm going to jump ahead to
pdf export times again exporting two
different projects one large house
completely constructed 16 to 20 pages
and one large commercial project that
has a couple less pages it's not fully
completed so what we found is both of
the export times on both machines were
relatively identical now this is
obviously because of the read write
speeds on the ssd that means there is
actually no difference in performance in
read and write speeds which is what
would be expected in a typical test
anyway now this is where the m1 ultra
really really impressed me if you
convert any of your projects to a
wireframe and they're pretty heavy
intense projects you're going to see a
million and one different lines so once
you actually rotate an orbit around
traditionally speaking for me at least
on the pc it has always taken a couple
seconds to load so when i turned the
house into a wireframe orbit it around
it took about 3.75 seconds to refresh
and actually generate the image i needed
for the apartments to do the same thing
it took 8.2 seconds so every time i
orbit it around in a wireframe situation
it almost took 10 seconds of my time to
simply sit there and wait meanwhile the
m1 ultra absolutely obliterated it
there's no point showing you a time
because there was no lag you could
literally rotate that full wireframe
model on both the house and the
apartment with zero second delay if you
think that's impressive we took a 3d
marquee from the floor plan and
converted it into a wire frame sectional
3d now both on the house and the
apartment this took a little bit of time
on the house it took 4.54 seconds and on
the apartment it took 7.81 seconds
now on the mac studio it actually
obliterated them again the house took
2.38 seconds making it 47 faster on a
small project or it took
2.23 seconds making it
71.4 percent faster on a large project
if you add up all of these seconds
consecutively throughout the day that is
a huge amount of productivity
enhancement for simply going to a better
machine now last but not least is a
simple render test taking any image from
any of the projects i took the house put
on the front on elevation view and
rendered an 800 by 600 pixel project it
is a very quick test it is meant to be
very minor on the pc it took 50 seconds
whereas on the mac studio it took 24
seconds and there you have it the m1
ultra mac studio twice as fast twice the
price for now my name is david thomich
and i'll see you next time